welcome back foreign ministers of the UK
US Canada and Australia say they're
deeply concerned by China's imposition
of new security laws for Hong Kong in a
joint statement they warned the
legislation will curtails people's
liberties and erode the territory's
autonomy meanwhile thousands have
protested against the new laws which
activists say may be used to suppress
political activity let's speak to the
former British governor of Hong Kong
Lord Paton Chris Patten thanks very much
for being with us so we don't know
precisely what's in the security bill so
can we be sure it is a threat to the
high degree of autonomy or the end of
one country two systems' well we can if
they go ahead as they've said in which
case it would be a very very sad and bad
day for Hong Kong and a bad day for the
world really because it would
demonstrate that China is well the
Chinese communist regime is a regime
that nobody can trust it breaks its word
at will we know that's been happening
elsewhere but to see it happening in
this sort of comprehensive way in Hong
Kong would be deeply sad and helped to
destroy a great city snuffing out the
aspirations of so many millions in Hong
Kong
I think the foreign foreign foreign
ministers have been very sensible to
leave a door open so that if the Chinese
Communists back off now and we can try
to restore something of approximating to
normality and they've said that if that
happens there should be an effort to
promote reconciliation between the
community and the government and I guess
insofar as that's possible with Beijing
I think they're sensible to leave that
door open but by and large I think it's
an example of how outre liberal
democracies and other countries around
the world are by China's continuing
bullying behavior taking advantage of
the fact that so many of us preoccupied
with fighting a pandemic which got as
bad as it did partly because of the
mendacity and secrecy of the Chinese
Communist Party despite those
brave dr. Hilu ham yeah I mean sedition
and subversion could cover many things
do you fear Chinese security forces
could operate widely in Hong Kong and
and people be being taken to the
mainland for trials that sort of thing
of course and one of the things which
apparently the law is going to allow is
for the Ministry of State Security
Beijing's equivalent of the KGB to
operate in Hong Kong it's got a it's got
a long reputation for coercion and
torture and it's not gonna be in Hong
Kong if it does go to Hong Kong order to
sell dim sum and or sandwiches as Tom
jugen after the very good Conservative
MP pointed out the other day so I think
there are real and substantial worries
and this isn't simply people making
things up the Hong Kong Bar Association
like like lawyers all around the world
has picked apart the proposals and shown
how they're not only out of line with
the basic law out of line with the joint
declaration a treaty that we signed with
with that with China but also completely
contradict the International Covenant on
Civil and Political Rights which is
supposed to exist in Hong Kong and it's
something which the UN Security Council
has referred to from time to time that
yeah it's the security laws may be fine
they have to comply with that
International Covenant so on all those
counts it's an appalling thing for the
Chinese to be threatening to do and
would undermine Hong Kong's economy as
well as doing terrible damage to Hong
Kong's reputation right do we now have
an obligation to three million or so
Hong Kong citizens who have this British
national now nationality overseas bno
British nationals but no right of abode
in this country should now that change
do you think should we be prepared to
take as many of those who want to come
in well I think Dominic Rob has made it
clear that if the Chinese Communists go
ahead with this law and Ram it through
um Hong Kong promulgating it rather than
allowing the Legislative Council to
debate it and one of the things which of
course is clear is the Chinese are doing
this partly because they're terrified
witless of the Legislative Council
elections in September which would
almost certainly result in a pan
democratic majority and being being
elected because people are so outraged
about what's been happening over the
last year so I think that and the
Chinese want to ram this through if they
possibly can without any consultation
and that would be hugely damaging and in
those circumstances I think mr. rabe
today made it clear that we'd look at
the rights of people who are and it's
not as many as you suggested not nearly
as many the rights of those who have
what are called bno passports and extend
their rights with a possibility further
along of them being able to live here
permanently but I think that it's worth
remembering that some of those who are
who were that sort of quislings for this
policy and who are standing up for it in
Hong Kong and there aren't many of them
who are members of the government
actually have full British passport it's
outrageous it's extraordinary if a
critical yeah but there it is things one
has to deal with it you and I will
remember from our time there very often
the people who were most enthusiastic
about Chinese communism all had
passports in their back pockets to get
out if necessary yeah I mean but that
brings me to my next point I mean how
can we talk about democracy and freedom
in Hong Kong if we never really gave the
people of Hong Kong that democracy at
all until the last moment when it was
you know you I mean there is an argument
there that keeps being used by China in
fact well I tell you for this first of
all one of the reasons why Hong Kong
didn't have full democracy was whenever
it was proposed Chinese officials would
say you mustn't do that if you do that
people in Hong Kong will think you're
preparing from independence like
Malaysia or Singapore so don't allow any
democracy we introduce steps which just
made sure and the Chinese allegedly
agreed with this that Hong Kong would
have a reasonably accountable system of
government and the Chinese themselves
promised
that after 1997 Hong Kong would be able
to determine its own rate of democratic
development but this isn't particularly
about democratic development this is
about the rule of law this is about the
politicization of judges this is about
introducing in to Hong Kong what are
regarded as crimes in communist China
the sort of crimes in communist China
which have led to over a million people
in Xinjiang being locked up in what
amounted concentration camps
now this isn't just about em voting in
elections that I'm in favor of that and
it's fear of that which is partly
provoked what the Chinese are up to it's
about all those more basic rights which
are so important not only to individual
citizens but also to the business
community one reason why why Hong Kong
is dealt so much better with the
pandemic of the corona virus in other
places it has a free media and so people
were able to report what had been
happening in China and take take action
in sufficient time so I mean the u.s.
now effectively says Hong Kong is
basically China and they all treat it is
having no special status
it is now basically part of Communist
China I mean should we do the same or
would is that exactly what China would
like us to do maybe isn't what cheer
China would like is like us to do let's
be clear that China is is is what's
creating the problems in Hong Kong
they're all completely unnecessary over
the last year or so yeah it's worth
remembering that the Act you're talking
about the Hong Kong new u.s. Act was
actually got through Congress while I
was governor and I used to go and lobby
there for it in Congress and for most
favored nation status for both China as
well as Hong Kong because I always
believed that we wanted to safeguard the
economy of Hong Kong I don't think we
should take any measures which make it
more likely that people in Hong Kong
will lose their jobs and will want to
emigrate all will lose their their
prosperity I think that would be wholly
wrong but I do think we're going to have
if the Chinese press ahead with this
we're going to have to look at our whole
relationship
ship with China and make sure that China
Chinese Communists pay a price for some
extent it may be use of the sort of
Magnitsky and powers which the Chinese
which the US Congress took in relation
to to Soviet Union to Russia and we're
after the Ukraine and that may be one
way forward but above would in the short
term I think we in this country who have
the main moral legal political economic
responsibility among the nations of the
world for what happens in a Hong Kong
need to work with others because we're
not big enough to do it on our own work
with others as we have been doing and I
congratulate mr. Rob on the statement
today work with others to make sure we
have a policy which defends our values
of liberal democracy against this
unpleasant pushy bullying that Chinese
regime and let's do that and not do not
any raising the issue of the cc7
the g7 in a few weeks time but also
trying to put together an international
contact group of like-minded countries
which contain a play on a friend to Hong
Kong in about years ahead okay just a
minutes ago it just finally wasn't it's
all inevitable when you stood there in
the rain in Hong Kong with all the
ceremony going on and handing over to
China surely in the back of your mind
you thought well something like this is
inevitable before the 50 years is out
and anyway you know it becomes China's
to do what they want within Twitter what
is it 27 years time anybody wasn't it's
all inevitable no I don't think it was
and even though China didn't behave
perfectly after 1997 it rode back on
some of the promises if they had
interfered too much by and large things
went in hot went all right in Hong Kong
for about 12 or 13 years after we left
what has changed is Xi Jinping Xi
Jinping is a very different sort of
dictator and he's one who wants to
export what he thinks is China's power
that's why he's broken his word all over
the place to her but to President Obama
over the South China Sea that's why he's
bullying Taiwan
that's why he's cracked down trying to
bury the wiggers in in in Xinjiang
that's why he was trying to believe the
Australians the other day because they
wanted an inquiry into how the
coronavirus had started after all the
assurances they'd have from China and he
threatened them with trade sanctions we
have to work together in dealing with
China I'm not saying we have to end our
relationship you can't end your
relationship with a with a country
however unpleasant its regime which is
responsible for 1.3 1.4 billion people
but you have to ensure that if you reach
agreements with them they stick to them
otherwise your dust and it's very
important for us to recognize that as
liberal democracies we really have to
work together otherwise we're going to
undermine all the values and standards
we stand for not least in relation to
international cooperation and the rule
of law okay
Lord Patton thanks very much for joining
us thank you thanks very much